[Aplausos]
cuando estás embarazada
te da por cambiar y por remodelar todo
tumbas paredes o bueno fastidias hasta
que alguien las tumbas
mandas a cambiar las tuberías de la casa
o te da por limpiar las juntas entre las
baldosas de cerámica hasta que queden
bien bien bien blancas por eso ese día
mis compras eran tenía 36 semanas de
embarazo una segueta unos guantes de
carnaza y un tinte para el cabello
la cual estaba larguísima y cuando
finalmente me tocó pagar el supervisor
se acercó a la cajera y le llamó la
atención amiga pero por qué no pasaste a
esta señora antes que ese bebé ya casi
van a hacer
como muy histriónicamente se puso los
guantes agarro las secretas y dijo menos
mal que aquí tendríamos todo lo
necesario para hacerle una cesárea hasta
este tinte para que esté bella
todos nos reímos pero yo me quedé
pensando en cómo se percibe el
nacimiento en venezuela- los bebés nacen
por cesárea
así sea improvisada en el pasillo de una
tienda por departamentos y además tienes
que estar bella
meses después comencé a filmar la
fotografía de nacimientos para un
documental y efectivamente la percepción
de que el supervisor de la tienda
comenzó a convertirse en realidad para
el momento un 90% de los nacimientos en
clínicas privadas en venezuela eran por
cesárea
esa cifra no ha cambiado mucho
y en hospitales públicos era alrededor
de un 40 a 50 por ciento
en nuestras pequeñas estadísticas
personales yo les quiero preguntar aquí
cuántos niños cuántos bebés conocen que
hayan nacido en los últimos diez quince
años por cesárea
cuántos niños y cuántos bebés conocen
que hayan nacido en ese mismo temporada
en venezuela por parto
fue así
sin embargo gracias a ese documental
como mi trabajo me llevó a convertirme
en fotógrafa de nacimientos yo estoy
presente en el momento más poderoso e
increíble en la vida de cualquier mujer
y cualquier hombre yo tengo el mejor de
los trabajos yo narro la felicidad
y es además gracias a esas imágenes y
gracias a esos sonidos que yo luego les
entrego a esas familias es la manera en
la que ellos van a recordar ese hito en
sus historias 200 bebés después puedo
decir que he visto a la vida expresarse
de muchas maneras he acompañado a
familias que toman la vía esperada de
una cesárea cómodamente programada en la
que un maquillador toca tu puerta a las
5 de la mañana y un par de horas después
sales rege fabuloso a conocer a tu bebé
pero también he acompañado a otros que
deciden dar a luz en su casa en la
comunidad familiar resultaban a su cama
a su almohada
he visto como unos gemelos llegan a
convertir en familia a una pareja
después de muchos años de tratamientos
de fertilidad fallidos también he
acompañado mamás que sanan malas
experiencias anteriores teniendo partos
vaginales después necesarias porque si
es posible si tu primer hijo nació por
cesárea el segundo puede nacer por un
parto también
he acompañado a esas otras mamás que
desde muy temprano comienzan a vivir los
retos de la maternidad con bebés
prematuros
lloré las lágrimas confundidas de unos
padres que en pleno siglo 21 con todos
los avances pruebas genéticas y
tecnología disponible el mismo día del
nacimiento se dieron cuenta que su bebé
tiene síndrome de dawn
otra mañana fuera del quirófano recién
conteniendo la respiración durante nueve
minutos
hasta que escuché llorar muy bajito al
bebé que estaban reanimando
también acompaña el silencio a aquella
bebé que simplemente no respiro al nacer
y es que si nos ponemos a ver se va
analizar un momento tan importante y tan
definitivo como el nacimiento
pero cómo no hacerlo si estos son los
referentes que tenemos el romance
adolescente más famoso de esta
generación termina en un embarazo
peligrosísimo con un nacimiento en el
que la protagonista muere o nos
encontramos con mujeres sudorosas
gritando enloquecidas que no sabemos si
pertenecen a una comedia romántica o más
bien al exorcista
pero entonces es desde ahí desde estos
referentes y desde el miedo y desde la
desinformación que me ha tocado
acompañar mamás que programaron una
cesárea porque no querían sentir dolor
para encontrarse con que es una cirugía
mayor y duele y entonces en vez de lucir
frescas y radiantes en mis fotos lucían
desencajadas y frustradas porque en esa
desinformación nadie les dijo que
tendrían que entrar solas y pasar horas
desnudas en ayunas nerviosas en la fría
antesala de un quirófano esperando por
una operación que muchas veces no
comienza puntualmente o que su esposo no
vio poder acompañarlas ni siquiera en el
momento del nacimiento de su bebé nadie
les dijo que les iban a enseñar el bebé
de lejitos y ni un beso volado iban a
poder darles
nadie les dijo que se lo iban a llevar a
un lugar misterioso llamado retén donde
lo iban a mantener secuestrado por
cuatro o seis horas alimentando lo con
biberones con azúcar cuando ellas
hubiesen querido ser las primeras que
los alimentarán de sus pechos
pero el nacimiento puede ser una
experiencia muy diferente
sin embargo tú no puedes acercarte a un
momento tan importante y tan definitivo
sin información y sin espíritu crítico
qué tal si
asumimos la selección del lugar donde
daremos a luz y las personas que nos van
a acompañar y atender con el mismo
detalle y la misma minuciosidad con la
que escogemos el color rosado de las
cortinas del cuarto de la bebé
yo tengo que admitir que la fotografía
de nacimientos se ha convertido en una
moda es parte de todas las cosas que
hacemos una larga lista de cosas que
hacemos cuando estamos embarazadas
emocionadísima podría ir por ejemplo
después de la fiesta de la revelación
del sexo no sé si saben qué es pero es
la última tendencia hacen una fiesta los
invitados se dividen en equipo hembra
varón se reúnen alrededor de un globo
carísimo que explotan
y de ese globo sale humo rosado o azul y
así sabemos cuál es el sexo del bebé
aunque la fotografía de nacimiento
podría ser algo superficial para mí es
un género que encierra una gran paradoja
porque ha servido desde mi experiencia
para que algunas cosas cambien
yo quiero hablarles por ejemplo el
nacimiento de alan y alan y necesitaba
una cesárea para nacer
pero su obstetra siguiendo prácticas que
ya son comunes en otros países hizo la
decisión en el abdomen saco la cabecita
de la cni y le pidió a su mamá que se
incorporara y la pujar a que participara
en el nacimiento y una vez que salió la
metió dentro de los campos estériles
directo al pecho de su mamá
para cumplir con un concepto llamado
apego oportuno
recomendado con mucha firmeza por la
organización mundial de la salud que
dice que los bebés deben llevarse al
pecho de la mamá directamente después
del nacimiento durante por lo menos la
primera hora de vida para iniciar la
lactancia materna
la información basada en evidencias nos
habla de el nacimiento como un momento
definitorio de lo que será la salud
posterior de ese ser humano cuando los
bebés están en el útero se encuentran en
un ambiente estéril y es apenas cuando
salen cuando se termina de formar su
microbiota antes se le decía flora
intestinal ahora se le dice el
microbioma a ese ecosistema de
microorganismos que conviven
simbióticamente dentro de nuestro cuerpo
y que por ejemplo ayudan a nuestro
sistema inmunológico a combatir y a
protegernos de enfermedades
estos estudios recientes no nos hablan
por ejemplo de que un equilibrio o un
desequilibrio en el microbioma puede ser
luego resultar en que desarrollamos
enfermedades autoinmunes como el lupus
como la diabetes alergias asma
obesidad y algunos tipos de autismo
entonces imagínense si hay un porcentaje
alto de la población que tenga un
microbioma que no esté equilibrado y que
tenga más susceptibilidad a desarrollar
estas condiciones en su adultez esto
podría convertirse en un problema de
salud pública
que necesitamos para tener un microbio
más saludable en el momento del
nacimiento que además es como un momento
como muy definitivo
necesitamos que el bebé nazca por vía
vaginal porque es en ese momento en el
que se va a inocular de las bacterias
que están en el tracto vaginal y en el
ano de la madre
necesitamos que lo haga con los
microorganismos correctos y no con una
bacteria intrahospitalaria por ejemplo
que sabemos que son tan peligrosas
bueno allí los bebés venezolanos estamos
en desventaja o están en desventaja
porque la mayoría o muchos de ellos
nacen por cesárea
luego el segundo pilar importante para
la formación de un microbio más
saludable es el apego oportuno durante
una hora piel con piel con mama
el tercer factor determinante es la
lactancia materna durante por lo menos
dos años tal y como lo recomienda la
organización mundial de la salud
todo esto viene a cuento porque yo
expliqué
todas todo esto cuando publique las
fotos de alan y en mis redes sociales
y entonces a los pocos días me di cuenta
de que quizás esas fotos comenzaron a
influir en lo que pasó frente a mis
cámaras
las mamás comenzaron a exigir lo doctor
nazca como nazca mi bebé
yo quiero apego
y los mismos doctores e incluso
comenzaron a avisarme aldrina atenta que
voy a ser apego para este lado
poco a poco en algunas clínicas los
protocolos comenzaron a cambiar y cada
vez es más común que yo vea a bebés que
salen del quirófano pegados del pecho de
su mamá
en venezuela
apenas son unos pocos minutos de apego
lo que se hace
en estos casos específicos
pero siempre eso va a ser mejor que nada
y es que los protocolos que se siguen en
las clínicas venezolanas son obsoletos y
no están basados en evidencias
científicas
pero son las mamás informadas que se
adueñan de la experiencia y la hacen
suya quienes pueden hacer que eso cambie
porque el nacimiento va más allá de un
acto médico es un evento familiar
en el que los roles cambian
los legados se transmiten
y todo es nuevo hasta los sabores
y entonces bueno siempre habrá quien me
diga ay el drina por es que yo en las
clínicas donde tú trabajas yo voy a dar
a luz en un hospital o en esta clínica
super anticuada bueno yo me tengo que
conformar con eso yo les quiero hablar
de ladies o ladies me contactó porque
ella quería ser personajes del
documental que dio inicio a toda esta
historia mía con los nacimientos ella
estaba embarazada de su segundo bebé
y convencida de que no quería que le
pasara lo mismo que le pasó en su
primera en su primer parto que tuvo que
recorrer todos los hospitales de caracas
el trabajo de parto
hasta que finalmente fue admitida en una
ella estaba convencida de que si se
hacía acompañar por una cámara la iban a
tratar bien
pero además
muy astutamente ella se había hecho
amiga de todo el hospital donde esperaba
ser atendida porque ahí era donde se
hacía su control prenatal de todos desde
el director hasta el de mantenimiento y
a todos se había ocupado de expresarles
que quería un parto tranquilo sin
intervenciones sin apuros y sin
maltratos además esta vez sí hizo un
curso prenatal gratuito que encontró en
su comunidad
se aprovechó el acompañamiento de una
dura voluntaria que estuvo con ellos
durante todo el trabajo de parto
llegamos al hospital como a las cinco y
cincuenta y cinco de la madrugada
a las seis y media escuchamos el llanto
de aaron cuando pudimos entrar a verlos
ese estaba pegado al pecho succionando
como un campeón cumpliendo con su hora
de apego y la sonrisa de oleivys era
absolutamente radiante e iluminaba toda
aquella habitación
después cuando lo entrevisté
y me dijo mira efectivamente esta
experiencia cambio mi vida y cuál fue el
aprendizaje aquí para mí
que con los recursos que se tengan pocos
o muchos las mamas curiosas las mamás
informadas y que escogen
mucho detenimiento el lugar y el
personal que las rodea cuando van a dar
a luz reciben un trato más empático y
respetuoso de ese equipo
porque también he aprendido durante todo
este tiempo que los profesionales que
dedican sus vidas a recibir bebés están
tan fascinados como yo por el milagro
del nacimiento cada día yo no puedo
decir que he visto al primero que no se
emocione con un con la llegada de un
bebé como si no fuese el primer parto
que está atendiendo
ellos están allí para abrazar para
contener para orar con las mamás y cada
bebé que reciben lo tratan como si fuese
su propio hijo o su nietecito y creo que
desde allí desde ese compromiso con el
milagro de la vida todos también están
comprometidos hacia evolucionar y hace
aprender
imaginemos
que nosotras las mamás informadas
ejercemos presión para que se cumplan
las leyes que existen en venezuela y que
nos protegen a las mamás y los bebés
durante el momento del nacimiento
imaginemos que junto a todos esos
profesionales promovemos los cambios que
harán que el día en el que nuestros
bebés nacen sea recordado como el día
más increíble de nuestras vidas gracias
a mis fotos
pero además también gracias a la
práctica del apego oportuno durante la
primera hora de vida piel con piel
aseguremos un futuro más saludable a
todos esos bebés que son la generación
del futuro gracias
[Aplausos]